[Music]
it's time once again
for the oscars the annual award show for
the year's best movies
in a year where no one could go to the
movies
but since nothing can stop hollywood's
biggest stars from giving awards to each
other
here are your honest nominees for this
year's best picture
prepare for a film about injustice
political activism
the whole world is watching and social
movements that couldn't have come
at a more timely moment oscar season
it's the academy awards of protest
and as far as i'm concerned it's an
honor just to be nominated in aaron
sorkin's first film to give the finger
to historical truth
since well his last four movies
featuring borat's wackiest accent yet
over the course of 10 days the
government called 37 witnesses eddie
redmayne's third
or fourth wackiest accent yet whether
we're given permits or not
we're coming and the guy from succession
doing an impression of cheech and chong
at the same time it's a tom collins i
know it's kind of a country club drink
but they're delicious
so get inspired for more of the
fast-paced sorkini speechifying that
could maybe almost change someone's mind
about something
if they were already open to the ideas
in the first place and you caught them
on a good day
chicken soup for the liberal soul
experience the moving story of black
panther leader fred hampton
snitch in an intimate portrayal of the
relationship between this backstabbing
and jesse plemmon's latest white boy you
don't want to mess with
leaving audiences with about as much
knowledge of the black panther movement
as forrest gump
sorry i had a fight in the middle your
black panther party that still
definitely deserves a best picture
nomination but it's kind of sting the
defy bloods got snubbed while spike
lee's literal film student got in
you do know you can honor more than one
black director at a time right
at least nominate delroy lindo you
cowards
from the colossal castles up top coanga
to the bustling boulevards of boys town
all of hollywood is in the tank for mank
that compelling kane chronicle from
fight club front man fincher has
everyone talking from film historians to
film festival programmers
heck even film preservationists want
hanky-panky from mr manky
don't have intimate knowledge of old
hollywood history well hit the books
junior any man jack who doesn't know
their shearers from their cells next is
gonna get all flipped around before you
can say irving j
thalberg oh brother gary oldman is the
cat's pajamas as the man who put the
mink in herman j
mankowitz a fella who was half the
actor's age when this all took place
stop by the trailer for another layer of
powder mr old man you'll get there
plus there's the lovely lily collins as
bank secretary
who takes notes on all of his opinions
and the amazing amanda seyfried as
mank's friend who listens patiently to
all his opinions
and the transcendent tuppence middleton
as menk's wife who sits
quietly while he has his opinions great
job james
maybe you'll get some opinions of your
own one day after all it's tinsel town
where dreams come true
so grab your most patient grandparent
for a retro revisionist rollercoaster
ride of righteousness relevance and
rebuke that may look like a classic film
that unfolds with all the aimless filler
of a modern day 13 episode netflix show
take that mr punisher you've just been
manked what good
prank mankers meet reuben
a hardcore rocker who loses his hearing
which is a nightmare scenario for a
musician
and i guess pretty bad for drummers too
watch him go through the five stages of
grief
with an extended stop in anger
yeah take that donut you've had it too
good for too long
in this shoe-in to win all of the sound
awards and continues the whiplash
tradition
of angry drummer movies that deserve
best picture but won't win
and hey at least riz ahmed is the first
muslim to ever get a best actor
nomination
so we're still hitting these firsts
after almost 100 years at the oscars huh
good for us yay def jam
let chloe zhao's masterful direction
sweep across the pristine beauty of
america
most of the time
for a documentary full of real people
plus a famous actor so that you'd
actually
watch it in this film that could be
viewed as an indictment of modern
capitalism
or an endorsement for how sweet van life
can be i mean just look at that puppy
solid as a rock got an indoor stove for
hot chow ample storage
more counter space and no landlord
breathing down your neck
has an lie to us living in a van down by
the river is
awesome bucket pissed
from the writer director who i still
haven't forgiven for being so mean to
lady die
comes the tale of a vigilante who uses
herself as man bait for sexual predators
so that she can give these creeps what
they truly deserve
a stern talking to careful next time you
go out now
in this film with parallels to another
story about someone in makeup who hates
society
oh no a lady joker with a powerful
message for girls
do not trust men if they were an
adorable comedic actor who peaked around
i want to see you the real you
it too mclovin don't kill bill for some
reason
from the studio who brings you horror
films that turn out to be elaborate
metaphors about the notion of family or
whatever
comes a movie about being an asian
family in america
which was already pretty scary without
putting a babadook or whatever in it
return to the 80s where despite what
stranger things in wonder woman say
was not covered in neon everywhere and
meet the yee family
a hearty band from california determined
to get out of the chicken sex and
business
in this stirring tale about how farming
is really effing hard
and marriage is even harder but at least
mountain dew is delicious
my favorite
whose deliberate pace will give your
brain enough time to connect everything
back to the simpsons
check it out angry dad who loves food
sad mom who's worried all the time
devout christian neighbor grandparent
who's starting to lose it
a rebellious boy and a smart and
respectful sister and they all cram into
a beat up station wagon
hey maybe they should have tried growing
tobacco instead of korean vegetable
okay i'll stop i'll stop veggie tales
anthony hopkins gives the performance of
a lifetime
as an old man refusing help for the
dementia that's slowly eating away at
his mind
that such a heartbreaking torturous and
cruel portrayal of a legends final days
there's no way you actually watched it
ah
new this year has been hard enough i'm
just gonna watch this tick tock to relax
instead
never mind the downer
starring all the things you actually
decided to watch this year
live action cartoons live action
cartoons we took way too seriously
all the new netflix shows all of the old
netflix shows
all of netflix until all that's left is
cooking and real estate shows
and he's not even eaten a taco before
you're a taco virgin
you gotta eat a taco with me i gotta be
your first taco
okay find those two lighting sixty
dollars on fire
your cat and the wall you glare at
during your neighbor's loud parties when
you know they aren't socially distancing
because that's a studio apartment and i
would love to have company too but some
of us are being responsible and i
haven't felt the warm touch of another
human being in months because of this
wasted year that's flashing before my
eyes
brad the oscars 2021
i don't care what the academy says this
scene from money plane was the purest
moment of joy i had at the cinema all
year
whatever you want to wager on the money
plane has you covered you want to bet on
a dude
an alligator money plane
until next time i'll be scooting my butt
across the carpet
and into your heart 3.6
not great not terrible happy birthday
nemita
despite the promise of info i was unable
to determine what if anything
a butt onion is supposed to be